Google I/O 2015 had
so much going on
that even if you were
there or tuned in,
you probably missed something.
I'm Mano Marks, a Developer
Advocate at Google.
I'm going to
highlight what's most
exciting for mobile developers.
Of course we have to start
with the Android M Developer
Preview.
M has changes to lots of
stuff, including permissions,
better battery usage,
and improved support
for removable media.
To help you develop
with Android,
we've released Android
Studio 1.3 Preview.
It gives you faster Gradle build
speeds, a new memory profiler,
and full editing and
debugging for C and C++.
Once you've written
an app, you want
to be smart about
how you earn money.
Using Google
Analytics and AdMob,
you can hide ads from
certain segments of users,
such as those who spend
a lot in your app,
and show ads to
your other users.
We also learned that
Google Play Services rock!
This was a big year for iOS.
Google Cloud
Messaging, which allows
you to easily push messages
to individual devices,
is now available for iOS.
You can now use a single
message transport mechanism
to reach your users in a battery
and network efficient way.
Also, we'll be using CocoaPods
as the default distribution
method for our iOS SDKs.
And if you're a
Cardboard developer,
the Cardboard SDK is
now available for iOS.
Oh, and let's not forget that
Google Play Services rocks!
The best way to let
people know about your app
is through word of mouth.
That's why we released the beta
version of App Invites, which
makes it easy for you to
let your users invite others
to your app.
And it's available for
both Android and iOS.
There are a lot of
mobile devices out there,
and it's hard to
test on all of them.
To help with that,
Cloud Test Lab
gives you automated
testing, and you don't
have to do anything to use it.
Coming Soon will
automatically test
apps that are uploaded
to the Play Store
across 20 of the
most common devices.
For the web, we released Polymer
1.0, making it easier than ever
to create fast, beautiful,
and interoperable web
components with a
host of new elements
to bring Google Services
into your mobile web apps.
And finally, we had a
great time teaching people
how to code with our SDKs.
If you want to get in on
that, check out the 25
self-guided I/O code labs.
There's too much going
on at I/O to be contained
in one video or even two days.
So we're going to keep
going all summer long,
with 100 days of Google Data.
Subscribe to Google
Developers Channel
and don't miss a single thing.
Also, check out our I/O
site for more videos
from the live sessions.
Or don't.
I'm an engineer not a cop.